Ja.
Guten Tag, ich heiße Mustafa Tabakci. Ich bin heute Ihr zuständiger Arzt.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen ein Anamnesgespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, wenn das wichtig ist, dann natürlich, ja.
Also, kurz zum Ablauf. Zuerst brauche ich Ihre persönlichen Daten und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie etwas nicht verstanden haben, geben Sie mir Bescheid. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Marta Baumgart.
Marta Baumgart. Ja. Also, können Sie mir langsam deutlich Ihren Vornamen oder Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Beides, ja. Also gut. Der Vorname ist Marta M-A-R-T-H-A.
Ja, Marta. Nachname?
Baumgart. B-A-U-M wie der Baum. Und dann Gart. G-A-R-T. Baumgart.
Ja, wie ist Ihr Anleiter? Frau oder Herr?
Frau. Marta ist ein Frauenname.
Also, Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre noch.
Wann sind Sie gerne geboren?
Am 8.9.59.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56 und ich wiege 84 Kilo.
Und 80 Kilo? Ja. Und? 1 Meter?
1,56.
Vielen Dank für die Information. Also, Frau Baumgart, was fühlt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also vorhin habe ich meine Küche aufgeräumt. Und mit einem Mal hatte ich ganz starke Schmerzen.
Na gut, ich habe da ein bisschen rumgewühlt und ich habe eine schwere Wasserkiste hochgehoben und an eine andere Stelle getragen und habe da unterm Tisch gewischt und sauber gemacht.
Und mit einem Mal hatte ich solche Schmerzen und ich hatte auch eigentlich so ein bisschen Angst, muss ich sagen.
Das fühlte sich ganz bedrohlich an.
Und die Schmerzen waren hier oben so in der Brust und das hat dann auch in den Armen ausgestrahlt.
Mit einem Mal tat mir der Arm so weh und dann habe ich auch so das Gefühl gehabt, als ob ich mit einem Mal Zahnschmerzen kriege.
Also, das war ganz ungewöhnlich.
Danke, ja.
Also, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau. Das muss unangenehm für Sie sein.
Also, Frau Baumgart, Sie haben aktuell Schmerzen?
Nein, das ist besser geworden. Ich habe mich dann hingesetzt und habe das alles liegen lassen und habe nicht weiter gearbeitet.
Und dann ist es mir wieder besser gegangen.
Besser gegangen.
Ja, und ich habe einen Schluck Wasser getrunken und habe mich dann ruhig verhalten, aber das war schon sehr beängstigend.
Und dann habe ich meinen Nachbarn, als er nach Hause gekommen ist, gebeten, dass er mich hier ins Krankenhaus bringt.
Nachbarn mit Nachbarn sind Sie...
Ja, der hat mich netterweise gefahren.
Ich verstehe. Ich glaube, Ihre Schmerzen sind belastungsabhängig.
Ja, das hat ja angefangen, als ich mich angestrengt habe.
Abhängig. Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10, wobei 0 kein Schmerzen, 10 sehr stark Schmerzen bedeutet?
Oh, das war schon richtig toll. Ich hatte das Gefühl, da sitzt jemand oben auf der Brust.
Ja, das hat schon gedrückt. Und das war über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle, vielleicht bei 7 oder 8 oder so.
7, 8, bei Strennung, aber in Ruhe.
Danach war ich zum Glück wieder gut.
Wann genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen bekommen?
Ja, das war heute Nachmittag.
Heute Nachmittag.
Ja, hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden in der Vergangenheit?
Nein, das kenne ich gar nicht. So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Also, haben Sie einen anderen Arzt, der es gesüchtlich aufgesucht hat?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, als mein Nachbar nach Hause kam von der Arbeit, habe ich ihn gefragt, ob er mich eben hierherbringt.
Haben Sie solche Beschwerden zum ersten Mal bekommen?
Ja, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so etwas habe.
Ich bin direkt ins Krankenhaus gegangen. Ich verstehe.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen plötzlich oder eher schlecht?
Nein, das hat ziemlich plötzlich angefangen, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin es nicht.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen wiederkehrend?
Nein, nein, als ich Ruhe gegeben habe, war es wieder weg.
Okay.
In Ruhe, weg, ja.
Ich verstehe. Wo genau verschwören Sie? Hinter dem Brustbein?
Ja, das ist vielleicht eine gute Beschreibung.
Hinter dem Brustbein.
Aber da hat es eben auch so im Arm wehgetan.
Ja, in dem linken Arm und auch unter der Kiefer.
Ja, als ob ich Zahnschmerzen bekomme.
Okay, ich verstehe.
In der linken, ich muss mir Notiz notieren.
Wie können Sie genauer beschreiben, Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, also das war so drückend und ziehend.
Ja, drückend, ziehend.
Ja, also ganz heftiger Druck.
Ja. Also, gibt es bestimmte Auslöse?
Ja, habe ich Ihnen ja gesagt, dass ich da...
Aus der Anstrengung und zum Beispiel kalter Wetter oder...
Das ist ja das erste Mal.
Das erste Mal, ja, okay.
Ja, gibt es etwas, was Ihre Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Na ja, die lindert hat sich immer bewegt.
Ja, beim Bewegung haben Sie Schmerzen bekommen, aber in Ruhe her?
Na ja, also als das losging, habe ich natürlich sofort aufgehört.
Da habe ich dann Ruhe gegeben.
Und dann wurde es besser, ja.
Okay, leiden Sie unter anderem von Beschwerden, anderen Schmerzen?
Na ja, also was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, dass ich so einen komischen Husten habe, ja.
Komischen Husten, ja. Seit wann?
Ja, also eigentlich heute Nachmittag, dass ich dann praktisch hinterher so Husten musste, ohne dass da eigentlich irgendwas kam.
Ja, leiden Sie unter auch Atemnot?
Nee, also das eigentlich nicht, nee.
Ja, okay. Fühlen Sie sich müde?
Ja, jetzt am Abend fühle ich mich schon so ein bisschen müde, ja, und auch so ein bisschen erschöpft, ja.
Ja.
Aber ich schlafe auch nachts wirklich schlecht.
Ja, es tut mir leid, ja.
Frau Baumgart, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Schlafstörungen, seit wann haben Sie das?
Ja, das habe ich schon häufiger. Ich muss halt nachts auch oft auf die Toilette, also zweimal eigentlich, wenigstens jede Nacht.
Und ja, dann wache ich auf und wenn ich dann wieder im Bett liege, dann kann ich halt nicht so schnell wieder einschlafen.
Dann fühle ich mich morgens halt so ein bisschen...
Leider muss ich auch durchschlafen, beide Schlafstörungen durchschlafen und auch einschlafen, ich meine, ja.
Ja, also ich wache halt auf, weil ich zur Toilette muss, ne?
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Naja, also nicht umsonst wiege ich so viel, ne? Eigentlich ist mein Appetit gut.
Okay. Frau Baumgart, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewöhnter Angebot ab- oder zugenommen?
Nee, das ist immer gleich. Also mein Hausarzt wünscht sich das zwar immer, dass ich mal ein bisschen abspecke, aber das ist nicht so einfach, ja.
Fühlen Sie sich gestresst oder normal? Im Alltag oder bei der Arbeit?
Ja, also besonders viel Stress habe ich jetzt nicht, würde ich sagen.
Okay. Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben in der Nacht häufiger Wasser lassen.
Ja, ich muss nachts zur Toilette, genau.
Haben Sie andere Veränderungen beim Wäsche lassen bemerkt?
Nein, das ist nicht schmerzhaft. Ich muss halt nur nachts raus, ne?
Okay. Also, Frau Baumgart, haben Sie Veränderungen beim Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Also jetzt, cool, jetzt in letzter Zeit oder so, nicht? Ich habe schon lange ein bisschen mit Verstopfung zu tun.
Seit wann?
Seit ein paar Jahren eigentlich, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber, Nachschweiß, Schüttelfrust?
Also ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrust?
Nein, nachts schwitzen muss ich eigentlich nicht mehr.
Okay, alles klar. So, bleiben Sie unter saueres Aufstoß und Sod brennen?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Ja, Bauchschmerzen auch?
Ja, Bauchschmerzen manchmal, wenn ich halt Verstopfung habe, dann ist das ein bisschen unangenehm, wenn ich dann zur Toilette muss, aber keine schlimmen Bauchschmerzen.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen bekommen, verspüren Sie z.B. Todesangst oder kalter Schweiß?
Also vorhin, als das mit den Schmerzen angefangen hat, das war schon so ein bisschen bedrohlicher.
Aber die Schwitze habe ich aber nicht, nee.
Ich verstehe, ich nutze mir ein Notis.
Frau Baumgart, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit in der Hauptdurchstadt oder ins Ausland eine Reise gemacht?
Nee, ich war eigentlich immer zu Hause, ich habe gar kein Geld um eine große Reise zu machen.
Frau Baumgart, wann war Ihr letztes Monatsvogel?
Oh, das ist natürlich schon lange her, das war so Mitte 50, also schon über 10 Jahre her.
Über 10 Jahre.
Und damals habe ich natürlich auch geschwitzt, daher kenne ich das noch, so mit Nachtschweiß, aber das habe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Jetzt kommen wir zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen, Frau Baumgart.
Also leiden Sie und leiden Sie an chronische, dauerhafte oder wiederkehrende Erkrankungen?
Ja, natürlich in meinem Alter und Sie wissen ja bei meinem Gewicht.
Also ich habe seit 10 Jahren so einen Alterszucker und da muss ich halt Metformin nehmen und dann geht das so ganz gut.
Dann hat man vor drei Jahren zusätzlich noch festgestellt, dass ich Gicht habe, dann taten mir die Gelenke so weh und waren so geschwollen.
Und ich habe natürlich auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und die Blutfettwerte sind auch irgendwie zu hoch.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Das hat man alles vor 10 Jahren festgestellt, als man dann auch gemerkt hat, dass ich diesen Alterszucker habe.
Alle Vorerkrankungen, ungefähr, wurden vor 10 Jahren.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Frau Baumgart?
Ja, die Gebärmutter ist halt entfernt worden.
Und zwar hatte ich eine Senkung und das hat mir große Schwierigkeiten gemacht.
Und ja, das ist dann eben vor 9 Jahren gewesen.
Vor 9 Jahren, ja.
Also, verliebte Operation, komplikation muss?
Ja, also das ist ja nicht so eine ganz kleine Operation, aber das war also nicht besonders schlimm.
Was hatten Sie noch?
Ja, ich hatte mal einen Arbeitsunfall und da ist das linke Handgelenk, musste operiert werden.
Und das war gebrochen und das war irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig, die Heilung.
Schwierige Heilung, ja. Wann war das?
Oh, das ist schon 15 Jahre her.
Oh, 15 Jahre, ja.
Ach ja, und dann habe ich natürlich noch ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen.
Wann war das?
Das ist jetzt so 7 Jahre her.
Auch auf der linken Seite, da hatte ich solche Arthrose in dem Knie, dass ich gar nicht mehr die Treppe laufen konnte.
Ja, die linken Seiten, ja. Sie wurden an einer Operation durchgeführt.
Da wurde eine Operation, also ich habe ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Was hatten Sie noch, oder?
Ja, das langt ja nun wirklich, das ist ja schon mehr als reichlich.
Sind Sie schon mal im Krankenhaus behandelt oder aus dieser Operation? Oder auch stationär aufgenommen?
Na ja, also damals, als das mit dem Zucker angefangen hat, da war ich einmal ein paar Tage in der Klinik, bis man das alles richtig hatte.
Und ja, dann eben bei den Operationen, da war ich jeweils im Krankenhaus.
Ja, wegen erhöhter Zucker, ja, im Krankenhaus stationär aufgenommen. Ja, ok.
Am Anfang, ja, das, ja, ok.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie nehmen gegen Zuckerkrankheit mit Formen wie hoch die Imusierung?
Oh, was steht denn da drauf? Ich meine, da steht 500 drauf und dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
500? Also, nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, also wenn ich mal so einen sauren Magen habe, dass ich so aufstoßen muss, dann nehme ich so einen Säurehemmer, das heißt Pantohexal.
Und dann nehme ich noch Valsartan für den Blutdruck.
Valsartan, welche Dosierung wissen Sie?
Oh, was steht denn da drauf? Ich meine, da steht 160 drauf und dann muss ich morgens eine nehmen.
Und wenn ich mit der Verdauung große Probleme habe, nehme ich solche Movicool Beutel.
Movicool?
Movicool heißt das. Das sind so Beutelchen, das ist so ein Granulat, was man auflöst und dann hat man keine Probleme mehr.
Ja, Valsartan, ja, ich habe nicht das akustisch gehört.
160 Gramm.
Ok.
Morgens oder morgens abends?
Nur morgens.
Ok. Was noch?
Das ist ja auch reichlich schon.
Movicool? Sie nehmen bei Bedarf Movicool oder?
Ja, wenn ich Probleme mit der Verdauung habe.
Ok, ich verstehe. Sind Ihnen bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Eigentlich kann ich alles ver-. Nein, was ich nicht nehmen darf, ist Penicillin.
Das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt. Also da muss ich, das darf ich nicht nehmen.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, also ich habe da irgendwie so einen juckenden Ausschlag bekommen und der Mund wurde ganz pelzig. Also das war unangenehm.
Mund?
Ja, das fühlte sich so taub an dem Mund dann.
Ok.
Das ist ja Hautaschlauch. Ok, ja, ich verstehe. Sind Sie schon mal, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Vollständig. Als Kind bin ich natürlich mal geimpft worden und natürlich habe ich auch ein paar von diesen Covid-Impfungen da mitgemacht. Aber jetzt schon länger nicht mehr.
Super, ja. Also haben Sie irgendwas Intoleranz oder Unverträglichkeiten? Keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Penicillin darf ich eigentlich, aber sonst kann ich glaube ich alles vertrauen.
Also, Frau Baumgart, wir kommen zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten. Rauchen Sie?
Oh, ich habe früher mal viel geraucht, aber vor 10 Jahren habe ich, ja als das alles anfing mit den Krankheiten, da habe ich das Rauchen aufgesteckt.
Ja, aber aktuell haben Sie nicht geraucht.
Zurzeit rauche ich nicht mehr, nee.
Ja, ok. Sehr gut. Das ist eine gute Entscheidung. Was haben Sie damals geraucht?
Ja, wie viele Zigaretten?
Ja, also so ein Päckchen hat mehr als einen Tag geraucht. Also ich habe meistens so 15 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht. Aber natürlich über viele Jahre.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, das waren 35 Jahre. Da habe ich viel Geld ausgegeben.
25 Jahre, ja.
35.
Ok, 35, ja. Also ungefähr eine Packung.
Nein, nicht ganz. Nicht ganz eine Packung am Tag.
Ja, ok. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, also ganz selten mal. Eigentlich, ja, wenn die Kinder mich mal besuchen, wenn es was zum Feiern gibt oder ja, mal vielleicht auch so ein Likör mit einer Freundin zusammen, aber eigentlich ganz wenig, würde ich sagen.
Oh, ja nicht ganz. Ja, treiben Sie Sport?
Oh, sehe ich so aus? Nein, also Sport treibe ich wirklich nicht, nein.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Also Frau Baumgart, haben Sie schon mal Drogen konsumiert oder Drogen konsumiert oder ausprobiert? Bitte nehmen Sie das mal nicht.
Drogen? Nein, nein, also wirklich nicht. Nicht Drogen, sondern Sport.
Ja, ok. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die müssten ja schon sehr alt sein. Mein Vater, der lebt tatsächlich noch, der ist über 90, ja. Aber ja, der ist schwer dement und der ist in der Pflegeeinrichtung, also der könnte alleine gar nicht mehr klarkommen.
Und meine Mutter, die ist nicht alt geworden, die war keine 70 und dann hatte sie Leberkrebs und daran ist sie gestorben.
Siebzig Jahre, es tut mir leid das zu hören. Und ja, Ihr Vater wohnt in einem alten Seniorenheim.
Ja, in so einer Pflegeeinrichtung, der ist total dement, ja. Total dement. Der könnte alleine nicht mehr klarkommen.
Lungenkrebs, Ihre Mutter? Nee, Leber. Leberkrebs, Entschuldigung, nicht archäisch gehört. Ok. Also haben Sie Geschwister?
Meine Schwester habe ich, ja. Ist sie gesund? Nee, also die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich, aber die hatte vor einem Jahr einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt, ok, ich verstehe. Also Frau Baumgart, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Oh, ich bin Schneiderin, aber ich arbeite jetzt nicht mehr voll. Ich mache nur noch ein paar Stunden in der Woche.
In der Woche, ja. Sind Sie verheiratet? Nee, verwitwet. Also mein Mann ist vor Jahren verstorben.
Ja, ich verleite meinen heichlichen Beileid. Wohnen Sie allein? Ja, also die Kinder sind alle aus dem Haus, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie? Oh, wir waren eine große Familie. Ich hatte vier Kinder. Vier Kinder. Sind alle gesund?
Ja, klar. Die sind ja noch jung. Ok. Frau Baumgart, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder an mich fragen?
Ja, ich wüsste natürlich schon gerne, wie es jetzt weitergeht und was man machen kann, damit sowas nicht wieder passiert und ob man irgendwelche Tabletten nehmen kann oder so.
Frau Baumgart, ich werde um alles kümmern, damit es Ihnen wieder gut geht. Das klingt gut, ja.
Ja, aber es ist noch zu früh, eine bestimmte Diagnose zu stellen. Ich brauche ein paar weitere Untersuchungen.
Körperliche Untersuchungen und auch bildgebende Untersuchungen. Was für bildgebende Untersuchungen?
Ja, ich meine Röntgen-Torax und auch, ja ich werde EKG schreiben bei Ihnen und auch ich werde Röntgen-Torax durchführen lassen, ja.
So, bestimmte Diagnose erreichen zu können, ja. Ok, ok. Aber machen Sie keine Sorge. Wir werden unser bestes unternehmen, ja.
Ja, bitte bleiben sehr ruhig. Es wird gleich weitergehen.
Geht gleich weiter, ok, gut. Danke schön.
Wer hat uns denn das Licht ausgeknüpft? Irgendjemand spielt hier am Computer. Dass wir mit einem mal alle im Dusen sitzen.
Aha, bei mir wird es schon wieder hell. Da haben wir schon wieder Licht. Wer macht das? Gut, hat noch jemand Fragen?
Darf ich fragen? Immer. Wie lange haben diese Schmerzen gedauert? 5 Minuten oder 15 Minuten?
Ich kann das gar nicht sagen. Ich habe natürlich nicht auf die Uhr gerufen. Es kam mir lange vor, aber wahrscheinlich war es gar nicht lange.
Ungefähr 10 Minuten oder 15 Minuten? Ja, 5 Minuten ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich realistisch, ja. 5 oder 10, ja.
Und war Ihnen übert? Ja, so ein bisschen schlecht war mir da einfach aus Angst vielleicht, ne?
Und letzte Frage, sind Ihre Beine geschwollen? So ein bisschen geschwollen sind sie immer. Ich bin halt dick, ne? Aber besonders ist mir das jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Danke.
Entschuldigung, Sie haben gesagt über komische Hüsten. Sind diese Hüsten dauerhaft da oder gehen sie wieder weg?
Ja, also ich habe immer so ein bisschen Hüsten, aber das war jetzt ziemlich krass. Als diese Schmerzen da waren, hatte ich das Gefühl, ich muss sehr viel Hüsten.
Darf ich fragen? Ja? Ist Ihr Bluthoffdruck gut eingestellt oder mit diesen Medikamenten?
Ja, also ich messe den ja nicht selber. Ich gehe regelmäßig zum Hausarzt, immer wenn ich neue Tabletten brauche oder so.
Und dann guckt er immer und der sagt immer, ja, das passt so mit dem Walzertan.
Und gegenüber diese Hochblutfettwerte, nehmen Sie etwas dagegen?
Nein, da nehme ich nichts. Also wüsste ich nicht, dass da irgendwas für gut ist.
War Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig war mir eigentlich nicht.
Hatten Sie Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen, Herzstolper?
Ich habe das nicht mehr, ich hatte nur dieses Druckgefühl.
Danke.
Hatte das mit dem tiefen Einatmen oder Ausatmen stärker geworden oder sind diese Schmerzen atemabhängig?
Ich kann das gar nicht mehr sagen, das liegt ja jetzt schon zurück.
Aber beim Einatmen vielleicht, kann sein, dass es beim Einatmen sogar noch schlimmer geworden ist.
Danke schön.
Dass das noch mehr gedrückt hat, ja.
Dr. Oberarzen, ich habe einen neuen Fall.
Ich möchte Ihnen ihn vorstellen.
Sie können ihn vorstellen, ja, wer ist das?
Es geht um Martha Baumgart.
Sie ist 66 Jahre alt, am 8.9.1958 geboren.
Sie ist 1,56 Meter groß und 84 Kilo schwer.
Frau Baumgart stellte sich heute in Beteiligung ihrer Freundinnen oder ihrer Nachbarn in Begleitung.
Sie stellte sich in Begleitung ihrer Freundinnen und ihre Nachbarn in Begleitung.
Sie standen im Intermittier und haben erstmals eine rettlose Haltung mit Ausstrahlung in den linken Arm.
So wie unter Kiefer.
Unter Kiefer.
Lauter Passienten liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 7 bis 8 von 10 auf eine Schmerzskala.
Auf eine Schmerzskala.
Lauter Passienten würden die Schmerzen bei Belastung auftreten, in Ruhe linden.
Die Schmerzen seien in Ruhe verbessert, aber bei der Bewegung verschlimmert geworden.
Als Begleitender klagte der Passient über heute Nachmittag aufgetretenen Tustis.
Die Faktorik ist Todesangst.
Die Vegetative-Anamnese ist zweimalige Nektarie und Obstfassung seit mehr Jahren.
In Somnien wegen Nektarien, die folgenden Auffälligkeiten,
die Reiseanamnese ist unaufwendig.
Die letzte Monatsbrutung der Passienten war vor über 10 Jahren.
An Voroperationen seien beide Passienten die folgenden bekannt.
Seit 10 Jahren Diabetes mellitus type 1.
Das sind Vorerkrankungen, nicht Voroperationen.
Vor 10 Jahren war bei den Passienten eine komplikationlose Hysterektomie wegen Prolapsus durchgeführt worden.
Vor 15 Jahren waren die Passienten eine Osteosynthese am linken Handgelenk wegen Fraktur durchgeführt.
Das war ein Durcharbeitsunfall.
Die Knie-Analyse und die Prothese waren bei den Passienten im linken Handgelenk wegen Arthrose durchgeführt worden.
Die Besuchungsmedikation war, dass die Passienten mit 500 mg zweimal pro Tag, morgens und abends,
eine unbekannte Dosisierung bei Bedarf, also 160 mg einmal morgens und auch ein Mobilkol für Obst-Passionen bei Bedarf.
Die Passienten haben eine Penicillinallergie. Sie reagieren darauf mit Pyrrhythmias und Exantham sowie Parastese im Mundbereich.
Sie wurden auch gegen Covid-19 vollständig geimpft. Sie rauchen nicht mehr.
Aber sie haben vor 65 Jahren ein Packung Zigaretten geraucht.
Sie trinken Likö manchmal an Feierlichkeiten. Drogenkonsum und Sport wurden verneint.
In Besuch auf die familielle Anamnese teilten die Passienten mit der Vater wegen alter bedingter Schwache.
Sie wohnen im Pflegeheim.
Die Mutter ist im Alter von 70 Jahren verstorben.
Die Mutter sei am Anfang verwendet.
Sie hatte vor einem Jahr eine Myokartinfarkt.
Sozialanamnistisch waren die Passienten Schneider. Aber momentan arbeiten sie nicht mehr.
Sie sind auch schon im Rentenalter.
Sie sind auch verwitwit.
Sie haben eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Durchführen um Herzwande, Störungen festzustellen, zu beurteilen oder Herzkloppen.
Also Cardio, Herzkloppen, Insuffizienz und Herzkloppen.
Echokardiografie. Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden bitte über die Ergebnisse.
Ja, gut. Okay, jetzt kommen wir mal zur Manöverkritik.
Also einmal ist mir aufgefallen, wir haben natürlich viel Zeit gebraucht.
Sie haben ordentlich überzogen beim Anamnese-Gespräch.
Und das war das eine. Und wir haben wieder einen ziemlich krassen Unterschied sprachlich zwischen dem Anamnese-Teil und dem Berichtsteil.
Im Anamnese-Teil waren Sie sprachlich sehr viel sicherer als im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Was mir beim Anamnese-Gespräch aufgefallen ist, dass Sie manchmal Sachen mehrfach gefragt haben.
Sachen, die die Patientin schon erzählt hat. Da haben Sie dann nochmal nachgefragt und dann hat sie auch so ein bisschen ungeduldig reagiert.
Das habe ich Ihnen doch schon gesagt oder so.
Und ja, das war aber grundsätzlich denke ich mal, nach den Regeln, wenn man davon absieht, dass es eben ein bisschen lange gedauert hat, haben Sie aber viel Gefahr.
Was ich als einen groben Fehler einschätze, ist die Sache, dass Sie nicht sofort dieses Gespräch unterbrochen haben, um als erstes Vitalparameter zu kontrollieren.
Ich denke bei jemanden, der mit so einer Herzanginasymptomatik kommt, müsste man, sobald er schildert,
Retrosternal Schmerzen, Angstzustände, Druck, Strahlung in den linken Arm, in den Unterkiefer, müsste man sofort unterbrechen.
EKG schreiben, Vitalparameter überprüfen. Und das könnte Ihnen bei der Prüfung übel aufstoßen.
Da könnten Sie Ärger kriegen, wenn Sie das nicht machen.
Gut, und danach kann man dann entspannt, wenn man sieht, ja jetzt geht es der Patientin tatsächlich besser, jetzt hat sie nichts mehr.
EKG ist soweit unauffällig. Dann kann man weiter sprechen.
Ja, gut, ja beim Arzt-Arztgespräch waren ein paar Merkwürdigkeiten drin.
Einmal, ja ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie immer sagen, wir sagen ja Patientin und Sie sagen immer, Partie, Patientin.
Also machen Sie ein, fast wie ein J da drin, Patientin, nicht Partie-entin, nur so als klingt normaler.
Zwischendurch machen Sie was ganz Komisches. Das haben Sie beim Anamnese-Gespräch gemacht, nicht beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Also, so ein bisschen unverbindet, also kommt an verschiedenen Stellen.
Und das war so ein bisschen überraschend. Ja, wahrscheinlich eine Angewohnheit, die Sie nicht so schnell loswerden können.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, ja also Sie waren sprachlich deutlich unsicherer im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Das fing schon eigentlich an, wie die Patientin sich, womit sie sich vorgestellt hat.
Ja, das ist natürlich immer eine ganz kritische Geschichte, weil man versucht in den ersten Satz so viel reinzupacken.
Ich warne immer davor, zu viel Infos in diesen allerersten Satz.
Also Sie kamen in Begleitung Ihres Nachbarn, stimmt insofern nicht ganz.
Der Nachbar hat Sie dahergefahren. Der war glaube ich nicht mehr mit im Raum oder so.
Das war nur, Sie kamen wegen, ja deshalb kamen Sie, wegen retro-sternaler Schmerzen.
Und die sind plötzlich aufgetreten, bei starker körperlicher Belastung und haben sich bei Ruhe wieder gelegt.
Das Ereignis war am Nachmittag, hat wenige Minuten gedauert.
Es war für Sie angsteinflößend, ja und deswegen ist sie gekommen.
Aber versuchen Sie nicht in den einen Satz zu viel reinzubekommen.
Es fehlte nämlich irgendwo das Verb in den Satz.
Sie stellte sich vor, wegen kam nicht.
Lieber kurze Sätze machen, die aber dann richtig sind, sodass man verstehen kann, was ist denn da überhaupt passiert.
Und Sie haben eben diesen Auslöser, dass sie was schweres getragen hat und gewühlt hat in ihrer Wohnung, sich körperlich belastet hat.
Das haben Sie eigentlich nicht kommuniziert.
Sie haben nur gesagt, bei körperlicher Bewegung, naja gut, also körperliche Bewegung ist es auch, wenn ich spazieren gehe oder eine Treppe hoch oder runter laufe.
Aber sie hat ja sich angestrengt und das war der Auslöser und bei Ruhe war es wieder gut.
Es war ein einmaliges Ereignis.
Das haben Sie ja auch mehrfach nachgefragt, ob Sie das schon vorher hatte oder so.
Ein einmaliges Ereignis, aber es hat sie halt Angst gemacht.
Und ja, was sie nicht gesagt haben, dass sie auf Nachfrage weder Schwindel noch Luftnot noch Herzrasen noch Erbrechen noch Sod brennen hatte.
Haben sie ja gefragt, aber ist nicht wieder gekommen.
Dann haben Sie sich selber korrigiert.
Da haben Sie gesagt, die vegetative Anamnese ist zwei bis drei Mal Nektorie.
Ne, also unauffällig ist die vegetative Anamnese natürlich nicht.
Also wenn Sie sagen, sie ist unauffällig bis auf einen Punkt vielleicht, dann kann man das durchgehen lassen.
Aber wenn sie drei verschiedene Punkte hat, die in der vegetative Anamnese auffällig sind, dann kann man nicht mehr von einer unauffälligen vegetative Anamnese sprechen.
Also in der vegetative Anamnese ergab sich, dass sie unter Obstipation leidet, dass sie eine Nektorie hat und dass sie dadurch bedingt unter einer Insomnie auch leidet oder unruhige Nächte hat.
Gut, die Frage nach Gewichtsveränderung und nach auffälliger Beinschwellung wurde verneint, kam nicht.
So, dann kam die Geschichte mit den Vorerkrankungen.
Die haben Sie ja abgefragt bei der Patientin.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, die hatten Typ 1 Diabetes.
Ein Zweier, die hat doch ein Altersdiabetes, ein Alterszucker.
Also seit 10 Jahren und wird mit Formin behandelt. Sie ist ja keine Insulinpatientin, also kein Typ 1 Diabetes.
Und die anderen Sachen kamen ja alle, Blutdruck.
Ja, ist ja kein Wunder bei einer Frau, die so klein ist und so viel wiegt.
Ja, gut, dann kamen die Voroperationen hinterher noch.
Ja, gut. Knieendoprothese, Knieprothese, Hysterektomie und die Handgelenksfraktur.
Gut, dann sind wir, ja Medikamente war auch klar.
Dann sind wir hier bei der Familienanamnese.
Sie hat ausdrücklich gesagt, der Vater ist dement und ist deswegen in einem Pflegeheim.
Sie haben gesagt, der ist in einer Pflegeeinrichtung, weil er altersschwach ist.
Also es ist schon ein Unterschied zwischen Altersschwäche und Demenz.
Demenz führt einfach ganz schnell dazu, dass Leute im normalen Umfeld überhaupt nicht mehr zu betreuen sind.
Weil es einfach viel zu gefährlich wird und weil sie eine Gefahr für sich und andere sind.
Also die Demenz hätte ich da schon auch ganz wichtig gefunden.
So, dann kam noch was Komisches.
Die Frau ist 66 Jahre alt und sie hat gesagt, sie raucht seit 65 Jahren.
Nee, also die hat nicht ihr ganzes Leben lang geraucht. 35 Jahre hat sie geraucht.
Also seit 10 Jahren raucht sie nicht mehr.
Sie wird 30 Jahre alt.
Ja, sie haben 65 gesagt.
Und also sie hat 35 Jahre geraucht. Ja, gut. Eigentlich logisch.
Ja, dann natürlich klar waren sie auf ihrem Feld bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Worauf müssen sie achten? Diagnose, Differenzialdiagnosen, war natürlich alles klar.
Und dann kommen eben die Untersuchungen, Herzanzyme und EKG, Corona Angio gegebenenfalls, je nachdem.
Aber wie gesagt, diese Vitalparameter und EKG hätte man vorziehen müssen. Zwingend.
Ich glaube, das fliegt ihnen bei uns bei der Prüfung um die Ohren.
Da werden ihre Prüfer kein Verständnis haben.
Ich habe zuerst gedacht, es ist stabiler als ein Genopekturist. Deswegen habe ich es nicht so gemacht.
Aber ja.
Deswegen ist es interessant für mich, was die Kollegen sagen.
Ja, normalerweise in der Regennotfallaufnahme machen wir es so.
Das ist das Problem natürlich, dass diese Prüfungssimulation nie eine wahre Situation ist.
Sie müssen auch in der Wahrheit nicht nach einem Namen fragen, weil sie immer im Computer die Angaben haben oder sie haben Aufkleber von den Patienten.
Und sie wissen genau, wie der heißt, wie der sich schreibt und wann er geboren ist und bei welcher Krankenkasse der Versicherer ist.
Diese Simulationen sind einfach keine echten Situationen. Das muss schon klar sein.
Aber ja, jedenfalls, das wäre, das wäre okay.
Gut. Sie haben sich ein bisschen mit mir gestritten. Mit dem Verb an zweiter Stelle.
Ja, sie würden das immer machen. Sie machen das nicht immer.
Ja, hin und wieder rutscht Ihnen das rein. Auch ich werde. Ja, auch werde ich.
Das ist einfach, hu, jetzt sind sie raus. Das will ja nichts mit mir zu tun haben.
Schade eigentlich. Mal gucken, ob er wieder kommt.
Noch wieder an. Machen Sie netterweise Ihr Mikro wieder an.
Ja, gut. Also Sie machen es nicht ganz konsequent.
Ja, hin und wieder rutscht Ihnen das rein. Ziemlich oft machen Sie es richtig.
Aber hin und wieder passiert das. Danach. Danach ich werde oder so oder auch ich werde.
Ist nicht richtig. Danach werde ich.
Ja, so. Und gut, also die sprachliche Souveränität, würde ich sagen,
beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war nicht so groß wie beim Anamnese-Gespräch.
Und da sind die Satzkonstruktionen dann auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Versuchen Sie da sich vielleicht nochmal so Muster-Sätze,
so ein bisschen zu erarbeiten, dass Sie da nicht suchen müssen.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ganz gut. Gut. Wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, nächste Monat, im Mai.